there's new evidence that hong kong's
long-standing democracy
is dying its last pro-democracy
newspaper
is pulling the plug after hundreds of
police raided its headquarters
and arrested its top officials last week
apple daily is the name it's been a
relentless critic of china's communist
party
which now effectively controls hong kong
cbs news was the only u.s
broadcaster inside apple daily as raymie
inocencio reports
and anything but a good morning really
it's almost as if the new york times or
the los
angeles times were closing down today
apple daily stopped updating its
english language website last night it
aired its final news show
and employees charged that hong kong's
press freedoms are now dead
the final sign off for apple daily's
digital news program
then the thanks and tears started to
roll
some staff left with bags and boxes late
monday
others still burn the midnight oil for
the next day's paper
but after 26 years these halls may soon
go dark
and printing presses may fall silent the
company
unable to pay its staff the government's
frozen its assets
last week 500 police raided these
offices
arresting the editor-in-chief and four
other executives
accusing them of calling for foreign
sanctions on hong kong and
china this is the heart of apple daily's
newsroom
on possibly the last week of its
existence some people tell me that
they're sad because
it feels like their own funeral and yet
others are celebrating
laughing even clapping congratulating
each other and knowing that at least
some kind of ending is on the way
we want to have a happy memory in
ourselves
so you don't don't cry
meanwhile apple daley's 72 year old
founder jimmy lai
arrested last august could spend the
rest of his life in prison
reviled by beijing because of his
strident calls for
full democracy he's accused of foreign
collusion too
a red line in beijing's national
security law
a reaction to the 2019 people power
protests
the u.s says that law is a tool to
silence dissent
hong kong chief executive keri lam says
it's to protect the country
not prohibit journalism all those
accusations made by the u.s government
i'm afraid
are wrong in 2019 lai told cbs news he
was not
afraid for his future i want mince words
i suppose
saying that beijing hates you is an
accurate statement would you agree
yes it's an honor it's an honor
it's a patch of ownership yeah
and apple daily has asked the government
to unfreeze at least some of its funds
to pay
its staff we'll know that by friday if
not the last run
after 26 years will publish this
saturday
sad day in journalism a huge loss a lot
of people well that was raymie
innocencio
reporting from hong kong